[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend für menschen die es interessiert
wie es um frieden und sicherheit in
europa steht war das ein spannender tag
mister spock würde vielleicht
faszinierend sagt der französische
präsident erklärte die nato für hirntot
und eine immer noch frische deutsche
verteidigungsministerin deren
durchsetzungskraft noch nicht als
erwiesen gilt hat eine vision für die
rolle deutscher politik und deutschen
militär sind der welt entworfen wie man
sie in dieser konkret haid und
spannweite noch nie gehört hat mathis
feldhoff berichtet über visionen und
reaktion es geht um die zukunft einmal
die arme ausbreiten einmal umdrehen
vielleicht ein neues erkennungsmerkmal
für ein künftiges sicherheitssystem der
bundeswehr die ministerin schaut
interessiert was an ihrer bundeswehr uni
in münchen so erforscht wird für die
zukunft vielleicht hat kramp karrenbauer
sich deshalb münchen als platz
ausgesucht um ihre vision einer neuen
sicherheitsarchitektur vorzustellen ein
land unserer strategischen lage und mit
unserem globalen interessen
das kann nicht einfach nur am rande
stehen und zuschauen ein satz der die
grundeinstellung der ministerin
beschreibt und der konsequenzen hat vor
allem für den führungsnachwuchs
ausbildungs einsätze wie in mali gehören
schon heute zum alltag der bundeswehr
deutschland ist bewusst vorsichtig aber
ohne die ausbildung der deutschen hätte
die malische armee im kampf
wahrscheinlich keine chance
anders als zum beispiel die franzosen
die in maries norden aber einen hohen
blutzoll dafür zahlen dass sie hier auch
deutschland sicherheit verteidigen
die deutsche ministerin muss sich das
ändern wir deutsche sind oft besser
darin hohe ansprüche auch moralisch hohe
ansprüche zu formulieren an uns und an
andere als selbst konkrete maßnahmen
vorzuschlagen und umzusetzen neue
einsatzszenarien für deutsche und
europäische soldaten etwa im
südchinesischen meer in syrien oder noch
tiefer in afrika künftig denken es sind
viele stichworte die kramp karrenbauer
in liefert eines ist ein nationaler
sicherheitsrat anstelle des bestehenden
bundessicherheitsrates der einfluss des
auswärtigen amtes würde wohl zurückgehen
die macht des kanzleramts deutlich
steigen
für die kanzlerin durchaus eine denkbare
variante gut ist dass es heute schon
eine bessere zusammenarbeit der ressorts
gibt also den vernetzten
sicherheitsansatz aber ein gremium wie
ein nationaler sicherheitsrat könnte
sicherlich auch helfen die gemeinsamen
bemühungen noch zu verstärken das
verteidigungsministerium hofft
offensichtlich dass es über den umweg
des kanzleramts mehr einfluss auf die
sicherheitspolitik bekommt ich finde das
überflüssig wir brauchen eine
öffentliche debatte dauert vorkam
karrenbauer durchaus recht aber keine
neue institution schon gar nicht wo bei
einer haben kramp karrenbauers
initiative baut auf die verbündeten und
die eigenen truppen
beides ist mangelhaft die material
ausstattung der bundeswehr es
bekanntlich schlecht über das bündnis
fällt heute der französische präsident
sein urteil
was wir derzeit erleben ist der hirntod
der nato so makro es gebe keinerlei
koordination strategischer
entscheidungen sein fazit wenn europa
sich nicht als weltmacht sehen kann wird
es verschwinden
der widerspruch kommt prompt vom nato
generalsekretär
und vor allem seiner gastgeberin heute
im kanzleramt
ich glaube ein solcher rundumschlag ist
nicht nötig auch wenn wir probleme haben
auch wenn wir uns zusammenraufen müssen
wir müssen unser schicksal sicherlich in
europa ein stück weit mehr selbst in die
hand nehmen aber die transatlantische
partnerschaft ist unabdingbar
kramp karrenbauer hat heute einen stein
ins wasser geworfen einer der im
gegensatz zu ihrem syrien vorstoß nicht
tagesaktuell ist und deshalb auch einen
morgen erleben könnte
kramp karrenbauers münchner visionen
kamen heute überraschend aber sie fielen
nicht vom himmel
das konzept gab es vor fast sechs jahren
schon mal aus derselben koalition nur
wurde nichts draus
auf der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
2014 kam die ankündigung größeren
deutschen engagements in der welt auch
militärisch
damals unisono von außenminister
steinmeier spd verteidigungsministerin
von der leyen cdu und dem
bundespräsidenten die bundesrepublik
sollte sicherheit gute partner früher
entschieden und substanzieller
einbringen
diese rede des präsidenten hat damals
thomas kleine brockhoff mitbetreut gaux
planungschef zuvor war er
usa-korrespondent derzeit und inzwischen
ist der vizepräsident des german
marshall fund einer hochkarätigen
transatlantischen denkfabrik guten namen
der kleber damals ging's los mit
steinmeier von der leyen gauck
prominenter konnte man so eine
initiative nicht starten und doch ist
sie im sand verlaufen warum soll es
diesmal anders werden
die lage wird ja nicht einfacher wenn
wir uns in der welt umschauen und in der
tat hat es ja ein münchner konsens nach
diesen reden gegeben der ist natürlich
ein wenig im land im sande verlaufen
angesichts der tatsache dass donald
trump die dinge nicht einfacher gemacht
hat und auch der parteipolitischen
konsens darüber wie die
sicherheitspolitik voranschreiten sollte
im wahlkampf zerbrochen ist im letzten
wahlkampf und sprach ja annegret kramp
karrenbauer tatsächlich von einem
deutschen engagement bis in den pazifik
um zu helfen japan und australien vor
china zu schützen müsste das nicht eine
nummer kleiner kommen ich habe das so
nicht verstanden ich habe verstanden
dass westliche länder
auch marineschiffe zur zur sicherung der
des rechts der freiheit der meere in
symbolischer weise in senden nur die
bundesrepublik tut das nicht aber ich
glaube man muss einen größeren kontext
sehen in dem den frau kramp karrenbauer
haute aufgeschlagen hat ich fand das war
eine bemerkenswerte sie haben das wort
faszinierend benutzen faszinierende rede
denn ich hoffe dass das ein anstoß war
die deutsche sicherheitspolitik aus dem
phlegma zu befreien in das sie sich
selbst rein geträumt hat nun muss das
aber erstmal auch in der deutschen
politischen realität funktionieren
da überhaupt denkbar dass auf kosten des
zurzeit von der spd besetzten
außenministeriums da die rolle des
verteidigungsministeriums in der
außenpolitik gestärkt wird durch so
einen nationalen sicherheitsrat der der
kanzlerin unterstehen wenn ich den
vorschlag richtig verstehe erzählt er
darauf gar nicht ab denn er will ja den
existierenden bundessicherheitsrat
reformieren ausbauen unterlegen mit
vorausschauender kompetenz unterlegen
und in diesem bundessicherheitsrat sitzt
ja auch der bundesaußenminister
außerdem darf man sich glaube ich nicht
vertun und man kann sich ein wenig
erinnern
es ist zwar jetzt üblich geworden dass
sich sozusagen verteidigungsminister
manchmal im bendlerblock verkriechen
aber wenn wir mal ein paar jahre zurück
kommen
auch franz josef strauß als
verteidigungsminister auch helmut
schmidt oder volker rühe haben ja den
ein oder anderen vorschlag zur
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik
beigetragen vielleicht muss man sich
unter dieser verteidigungsministerin
daran auch wieder gewöhnen
vielleicht wirkt es nur deswegen so ein
bisschen unrealistisch war ja
bekanntlich die bundeswehr in keiner
waffengattung wirklich funktionsfähig
ist und mit den wenigen
auslandseinsätzen diesem moment betreibt
schon an die grenzen ihrer belastbarkeit
geht was den steuerzahler angesichts der
ausgegebenen milliarden manchmal wundert
deswegen verstehe ich das was wir auch
keinen karren da heute vorgetragen hat
als einen umfassenden für reformversuch
sie versucht ja die institutionellen
rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern durch
den bundessicherheitsrat vorschlag aber
auch durch einen den versuch das
bundeswehr beteiligungsgesetz praktische
zu fassen
sie hat erinnert an die notwendigkeit
die verteidigungsausgaben zu erhöhen und
sie hat das ganze in einem bündnis
politischen rahmen hineingepackt indem
sie vorgeschlagen hat die sogenannten eu
drei zu verstetigen also frankreich
england und deutschland auch über den
moment des eu austritt englands hinaus
also das sind ja auch praktische
vorstellungen die sie geäußert hat die
einen größeren raum ich glaube wir haben
heute eine art ak agenda kennengelernt
welche chancen hat denn eine ak agenda
angesichts der tatsache dass in
deutschland
dass er im moment auch irgendwann wieder
auf neuwahlen zustrebt doch bis jetzt
jedes mal derjenige gewonnen hat die
wahl der für weniger militärisches
engagement eingetreten ist denken sie
nur an gerhard schröder 2003
sie haben es gesagt 2003 das ist lange
her da war die welt noch eine andere ich
glaube dass ist genau umgekehrt ist dass
das bundesbürger erwarten
handlungsfähigkeit und sicherheit und da
hat sich bisher noch kein politiker
getraut das als agenda zu vertreten
deswegen ist das ein bemerkenswerter
moment dass eine politikerin diesen mut
hat und die wähler werden entscheiden
dankeschön nach berlin
danke ihnen ein hauptadressat solcher
überlegungen bisher westlicher
sicherheitsgarant war heute in
deutschland durch den außenminister
vertreten
die rede ist von mike pompeo vertrauter
von donald trump empfangen vom deutschen
kollegen heiko maas das war eine heikle
begegnung man hat den aufprall
abgefedert mit einem gemeinsamen
besuchsprogramm dort wo deutsch
amerikanische partnerschaft mal
unkaputtbar jean-daniel pontzen
berichtet ein bisschen war es heute so
als ob man mit dem ex nochmal die orte
besucht die einst emotionale bedeutung
hatten ein rest gefühl ist da wie hier
in der mauer zwischen thüringen und
bayern wo pompeo einst stationiert war
ein rest gefühl und sonst lange war es
eine geschichte tiefer verbundenheit der
eine geschützte der andere dankte
geordnete verhältnisse ein gemeinsames
ziel
ausgerechnet als das erreicht war wurde
es kompliziert seit bei drei jahren noch
komplizierter america first und bei
geopolitischen fragen häufig deutschland
last das passt nicht zusammen so wenig
wie ihr naturell
so braucht es für hoffnungen schon eine
laune des kalenders
wenn es überhaupt in den ganzen letzten
langen monaten eine gelegenheit gibt mal
den versuch einer vertrauensvollen
zusammenarbeit mit den usa wieder zu
starten und darüber nachzudenken was war
eigentlich alles gemeinsam hingekriegt
haben einschließlich der
wiedervereinigung vor 30 jahren dann ist
das doch jetzt die gelegenheit das ist
nie mehr wird wie es war
dass narben bleiben glauben dass viele
hier wie dort zu viel zu grundsätzlicher
streit bei den themen iran nord stream
zwei handel und klima all das wäre auch
mit einem neuen präsidenten nicht
schlagartig gelöst aber egal ob demokrat
oder republikaner so können dorn fried
einst obama beraterin der nächste
präsident werde die regelbasierte
internationale ordnung wieder stärker
wertschätzen und erkennen dass sie us
interessen nutzt und nicht nur schlechte
deals produziert vielleicht glauben
manche wird eines tages er präsident
werden wollen soldat war er chef
abgeordnete 1 tram kritiker nun dessen
verlässlichste exekutive auch heute
inzwischen in leipzig höfliche folklore
das schon echte annäherung nicht
ich habe heute geschichte gesehen von
der ich in den 80ern selbst winziger
teil war ich bin stolz auf diesen
einsatz für frieden und freiheit der
unser verhältnis jahrzehnte lang prägte
wir teilen weiter dieselben werte und
sorgen manchmal unterscheiden wir uns im
ansatz aber das ist schon mal so bei
freunden und verbündeten
diese freundschaft ist auch das
fundament für all das was wir in der
zukunft gemeinsam auf den weg bringen
wollen wir wissen dass wir viele
konflikte nur dann gut lösen können wenn
europa und die usa an einem strang
ziehen und das wollen wir in zukunft
auch weiter tun und noch weiter
intensivieren
danach ging es in die leipziger
nikolai-kirche wo pompeius kopfhörer
symbolhaft standen fürs große ganze
probleme bei der verständigung aber viel
guter wille es weiter zu versuchen
zumindest hier hat das am ende geklappt
nachrichten von gundula gause
der streik bei der lufthansa hat
zehntausende passagiere getroffen
mit einem sonderflugplan und umbuchungen
wurde ein größeres reise chaos
verhindert viele lufthansa kunden
stiegen auf die bahn um oder änderten
ihre pläne
wenige stunden nach streikbeginn
kündigte der lufthansa-vorstand
schlichtungsgespräche mit der kabinen
gewerkschaft ufo an die gewerkschaft
stimmte zu hält aber an dem streik bis
morgen mitternacht fest die lufthansa
hat auch für morgen 600 flüge abgesagt
am wochenende sind erste gespräche
geplant
nach der landtagswahl in thüringen
regiert das amtliche endergebnis vor
dass der fdp den einzug in das
landesparlament bestätigt es sind
demnach 73 stimmen die den liberalen den
sprung über die fünf-prozent-hürde
ermöglicht haben damit ist die fdp
erstmals seit 2014 wieder in einem
ostdeutschen landtag vertreten und kann
bei der schwierigen regierungsbildung in
thüringen eventuell mitwirken
bundeswirtschaftsminister altmaier sieht
auch angesichts der landtagswahl in
thüringen eine erosion des
traditionellen politischen spektrums das
cdu spd fdp und grüne zusammen dort
keine regierung bilden könnten zeige
einen dringenden handlungsbedarf
die bürger müssten wieder mehr und
besser an politischen prozessen
beteiligt werden forderte der cdu
politiker und der bundestag müsse
verkleinert werden alle vier jahre um 40
sitze
bis eine angemessene zahl erreicht sei
derzeit gibt es 709
bundestagsabgeordnete der
rechtsausschuss des deutschen
bundestages will seinen umstrittenen
vorsitzenden brandner von der afd
in der kommenden woche abwählen der
thüringer fdp politiker hatte mit seinen
reaktionen auf den terroranschlag in
halle und auf die verleihung des
bundesverdienstkreuzes an den rock
sänger lindenberg für empörung gesorgt
es wäre das erste mal in der 70-jährigen
parlamentsgeschichte dass ein ausschuss
vorsitzender abgewählt wird
im nordosten von paris hat die polizei
zwei illegale flüchtlingslager mit mehr
als 1600 menschen geräumt die bewohner
der zeltstädte mehrheitlich aus
afghanistan und afrika wurden in
turnhallen und andere unterkünfte im
großraum paris gebracht frankreich setzt
damit seine ankündigung um für
geflüchtete mit bleibeperspektive im
ganzen land bis zu 16.000 neue plätze
zur unterbringung bereitzustellen
illegale migranten sollen
schnellstmöglich abgeschoben werden
die proteste in chile dauern an
zwar hat präsident pinera inzwischen
zugeständnisse gemacht und den
mindestlohn erhöht aber den
demonstranten geht das nicht weit genug
sie fordern premiere rücktritt auch
heute gab es in der hauptstadt wieder
zusammenstöße zwischen demonstranten und
der polizei
die proteste gegen soziale
ungerechtigkeit und hohe
lebenshaltungskosten dauern seit wochen
an
20 menschen sind bislang bei den
ausschreitungen ums leben gekommen out
of africa magische worte die magische
bilder wachrufen nicht nur von einem
großen roman und film out of africa ist
die herrschende lehre über die herkunft
der menschheit die ältesten funde von
auf zwei beinen aufrecht gehenden in
gesellschaft lebenden geschöpfen aus der
homo sapiens hervorging und sich über
die weite erde verbreitete stammen aus
dem osten afrikas 6 millionen jahre alt
bis jetzt out of africa ist out
ostallgäu ist in nicht 612 millionen
jahre alt sind dort die spektakulären
entdeckungen von forschern aus tübingen
sie stellen was wir über unsere herkunft
zu wissen glaubten auf neue füße
sozusagen
es ist ein weiter weg vom fortbewegen
auf allen vieren bis zum aufrechten gang
eines der wesensmerkmale des modernen
mensch
dieser weg ist weit beim individuellen
lernen im kleinen aber erst recht wenn
man die menschliche evolution betrachtet
dieser menschenaffen könnte der erste
gewesen sein der aufrecht gehen konnte
vor fast zwölf millionen jahren eine
spektakuläre erkenntnis denn bisher
dachte man dass sich der aufrechte gang
erst vor rund sechs millionen jahren
entwickelt hat und zwar bei menschen man
glaubte bisher dass das zwei beine
gelaufen
eine errungenschaft des menschen es
relativ spät entstanden ist und nun
hinten wäre es aber bei zwölf minuten
jahren das stellt vieles in frage was
ihr bisher das zweibeinige laufen über
die evolution kennen den spitznamen udo
haben madeleine böhme und ihre
internationalen forscher kollegen ihren
fund gegeben weil man seinen kiefer an
udo lindenbergs geburtstag fand dessen
musik im radio
da rauf und runter lief das oder
aufrecht gehen konnte lesen sie unter
anderem aus seinen gelenken 15 prozent
des gletscher haben sie gefunden was
viel ist weitere knochen wurden am 3d
drucker nachgebaut
ihr fund könnte nun vieles von dem auf
den kopf stellen was man bisher über die
entwicklung des menschen zu wissen
glaubte dass in frage gestellt wird ist
letztendlich das paradigma der
menschlichen evolution das paradigma der
menschlichen emotionen besagt dass die
gesamte menschliche evolution
ausschließlich nur in afrika statt fand
afrika als die alleinige wiege des
modernen menschen als der alleinige
ursprungsort von dem aus sicht der
mensch von heute mit seinem aufrechten
gang entwickelt hat die forscher aus
tübingen sehen diese these durch ihren
fund in einer tongrube im allgäu mitten
in europa nun widerlegt andere sind sich
da nicht so sicher
so wie professor thomas martin
vizepräsident der paläontologischen
gesellschaft
es ist die frage ob dieser diese
fähigkeit sich aufzurichten die
identische fähigkeit ist die wir auch
bei den frühen menschen finden oder ob
die frühen menschen das in afrika dann
unabhängig noch mal erfunden haben
und doch sieht auch er die neu entdeckte
menschenaffen gattung als einen hoch
interessanten fund an
es gibt neue impulse und es gibt einen
neuen anreiz neue fossile funde zu
machen denn wir brauchen neue
fossilfunde erkenntnis in der
paläontologie läuft im wesentlichen über
neue aufregende entdeckungen sowie einer
die wir jetzt hier sehen und da sind
noch viele funde
die es zu schließen gilt und da wird in
der zukunft noch einiges aufregender zu
tage kommen die unser was unser bild
noch mal fand sich grundlegend ändern
wird und so ist nicht nur der weg der
menschlichen evolution ein weiter
sondern auch der weg zur erkenntnis wie
genau sie bisher ablief was die
wirtschaftsnachrichten heute 12
millionen jahre später melden das wäre
udo aus dem allgäu wahrscheinlich schwer
zu vermitteln gewesen aber vielleicht
darf man ihn sicher da als einen
glücklichen menschen vorstellen
an den börsen wird eine mögliche
annäherung im zoll streit zwischen den
usa und china bereits mit steigenden
kursen gefeiert ein sprecher des
handelsministeriums in peking hatte von
einer schrittweisen abrüstung gesprochen
valerie haller ist das nur ein
hoffnungsschimmer
oder gibt es tatsächlich fortschritte
bei den handelsgesprächen ja die gibt es
tatsächlich jetzt kam nämlich auch die
bestätigung der amerikaner die
gegenseitigen strafzölle sollen
schrittweise gestrichen werden aber nur
und das ist entscheidend wenn sich die
beiden auf ein handelsabkommen einigen
dafür aber gibt es noch nicht einmal
einen termin
hoffnung macht das echt sich china und
die usa zuletzt angenähert haben und
mehr denn je unter druck stehen der
handelsstreit schadet beiden
volkswirtschaften und tram braucht in
zeiten des amtsenthebungsverfahrens
dringend einen erfolg
vielleicht lag es ja an den
unterschiedlichen zeitzonen in china
jedenfalls press stunden vor den
amerikanern forum verkündet den
verhandlungserfolg der unterhändler
seit über einem jahr überziehen sich die
usa und china gegenseitig mit
milliardenschweren strafzöllen vor allem
weil us-präsident trump den chinesen
unfaire handelspraktiken vorwirft
das handelsabkommen noch längst nicht in
trockenen tüchern aber die börsen feiern
schon mal neue rekorde der deutlich im
plus ebenso der dax nicht mehr weit vom
allzeithoch entfernt
ein hoffnungsschimmer sind die
äußerungen chinas und der usa
mehr aber noch nicht das wäre nicht das
erste mal dass die beiden kurz vor
abschluss dann doch scheiterten
eine lösung wäre wünschenswerte konflikt
wirkt sich negativ auf die gesamte welt
im dezember heißt es aus washington
könnte ein treffen zustande kommen und
dann hoffen wir mal auf gute nachrichten
danke eine meldung vom fußball in der
gruppenphase der europa league hat
eintracht frankfurt am abend bei
standard lüttich verloren
die belgier gewannen 2 zu 1 die
eintracht musste ohne unterstützung
ihrer fans antreten wegen wiederholten
fehlverhaltens hatte die uefa die
frankfurter fans ausgesperrt
die gesundheitsversorgung in deutschland
soll digitaler werden
der bundestag hat ein entsprechendes
gesetz von minister sparen gebilligt
dass ab 2020 gesundheits apps auf rezept
ermöglicht
außerdem sollen patienten leichter
zugang zu online sprechstunden erhalten
kritik kommt von der opposition und
datenschützern
weil die krankenkassen künftig
patientendaten für forschungszwecke
weitergeben sollen sparen argumentierte
die daten würden anonymisiert und die
hohen deutschen standards des
datenschutzes eingehalten
marius müller westernhagen muss man
generationen xy möglicherweise erklären
schauspieler musiker superstar
entwickelte sich vom rock proleten zum
armani rocker oder einer der
erfolgreichen deutschen künstler neben
grönemeyer maffay lindenberg hat in
deutschland zeitweise mehr platten
verkauft als phil collins oder michael
jackson und füllte stadien
dann hat er sich zurückgezogen lange
zeit hat man kaum noch etwas von ihm
gehört und jetzt macht er was
erstaunliches er nimmt sein über 40
jahre altes pfefferminz album neu auf es
wurde wie früher aber mit einer
salzkruste aus lebenserfahrung claudio
armbruster schmeckt das mir auch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit pfefferminz bin ich dein prinz dicke
johnnie walker lieder für die ewigkeit
lange her und immer noch gut und es galt
auch als rebellisch und zwar sehr
rebellisch das kann man sich heute wenn
man die texte heute liest gar nicht mehr
vorstellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die deutsche bank
das war vor 40 jahren und jetzt nimmt er
das ganze pfefferminz album einfach
nochmal auf eine zum studio umgebauten
kirche in woodstock ein paar
spitzenmusiker und die gut abgehangenen
lieder neu interpretiert
[Musik]
ich wollte keine nostalgie ich habe
gedacht ist es möglich wie im theater
ein altes stück also zum beispiel auch
klassiker wobei ich das pfeffer mit sei
sie gleich setzte aber nimmt man sich
dieses stückes an und inszenierte so wie
wir uns heute inszenieren würde
[Musik]
dicke damals ein skandal
ich kann im nachhinein heute verstehen
dass es leute gekränkt hat und dass es
für sie als ironie mich erkennbar war
und dafür kann ich mich nur
entschuldigen aber das stück ist da ich
habe versucht in der jetzigen
interpretation die die ironie mehr
spüren zu lassen
[Musik]
stopp
ich habe einfach das gefühl dass ich die
texte heute besser und tiefer begreifen
giselher zum beispiel dass schwule
liebeslied zum weinen schön
[Musik]
allmählich kam
nicht mögen
[Musik]
er war 30 also das gesungen hat erst
heute mit 70 entfaltet es seine ganze
traurige kraft kann man sagen er hat
damals mit 30 schon sein alterswerk
veröffentlicht sie ganz egoistisch sagen
ich lebe ganz gerne
damals ging energisch nach vorne heute
lehnt er sich zurück aus rock wird blues
altersmilde aber schön
[Musik]
jugend und alter beschäftigen auch
maybrit illner
da prallen die vorsitzenden der
jugendorganisationen von spd und union
aufeinander kevin kühnert und tillmann
kuban
die beiden werden geerdet von einer
energischen rentnerin die von einer
selbstverdienten kleinen rente lebt und
die super armen gegründet hat eine
selbsthilfe für leute mit noch weniger
geld und um 0.30 gibt es hier heute plus
mit christopher wehrmann und einem
bericht von der europa league
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren tief
karl otto hat gleich zwei ableger und
die verhalten sich komplett
unterschiedlich der eine ableger zieht
morgen ganz schnell weiter richtung
skandinavien
der andere ableger aber hierüber genua
der bleibt südlich des alpenbogens
gefangen und bringt stau niederschläge
100 liter regen pro quadratmeter sind
auf der alpensüdseite möglich und 50 cm
neuschnee und es fällt nicht nur in den
alpen schnee sondern tatsächlich auch
bei uns wie sie hier ganz schön sehen
können morgen so ab den
nachmittagsstunden kann es im
schwarzwald und auf der schwäbischen alb
schneien heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen im binnenland auf plus 4
bis minus 1 grad es droht also
verbreitet bodenfrost muss kann auch
glatt sein denn aktuell fällt ja noch
ein bisschen regen derzeit allerdings in
der nacht hier nordwärts aus deutschland
raus dafür setzt neuer regen ein
verboten sie und er breitet sich morgen
über hessen thüringen und sachsen anhalt
bis nach berlin und brandenburg aus und
dann gibt es die schneefälle in den
südwestlichen mittelgebirgen die dann
vorübergehend mal etwas nachlassen
am freundlichsten wird es morgen über
tag hier im nordwesten und die
temperaturen steigen morgen auf werte
zwischen sieben und zehn grad kühler
bleibt es im thüringer wald mit 5 und am
alpenrand mit drei grad kräftiger regen
fällt dann am samstag in der osthälfte
oberhalb von 700 meter ist auch schnee
dabei deutlich ruhiger geht es weiter
schönen abend noch